tracé avec l'air et christiane bonsoir
mesdames
centrale qui a peur du variant au micron
nouveaux variants qui représente un
risque élevé joe biden quand même invité
tout le monde au calme au québec chez
nous christian dubé demande à ceux qui
prévoient un voyage à l'étranger d'être
prêts à toute éventualité au retour
alors clair d'abord est-ce qu'il faut
imposer de nouvelles restrictions
pour les nouvelles restrictions
j'attendrai un peu il est urgent de
prendre son temps dans le contexte mais
on sait que ce virus là à une mutation
très rapide très fréquentes alors faut
être plus prudent que le virus est
rapide avait muté et on sait aussi que
la vaccination est efficace pour se
protéger du virus et que toutes les
mesures sanitaires nous préserve de la
transmission très facile du virus est-ce
qu'on peut partir sur ces bases là et
activer les mesures dont on sait
qu'elles sont efficaces d'abord et avant
tout question de nouvelles restrictions
va écouter j'aime bien l'expression
claire et urgente prendre son temps mais
il faut aussi être prudent je pense que
ça ne coûte rien
d'avoir peut-être certaines restrictions
temporaires mais de façon très
importante là où le bât blesse pour moi
c'est comment fait on pour accélérer la
vaccination en afrique notamment dans
les pays moins nantis
vous savez que en république
démocratique du congo
0,1 le dos car 100 personnes imaginé il
ya la plus grande partie des 54 pays de
l'afrique qui atteindront pas les cibles
de 40% puis en plus il manque 2
milliards de ce ring dont une grande
toutes les seringues pour la vaccination
qu'ovide alors tant qu'on aura un
maillon faible comme l'afrique c'est pas
parce que les africains veulent pas se
faire vacciner alors je pense dans ces
inégalités vaccinale qui connaissons et
là on en a les effets les effets réels
est ce que les canadiens doivent changer
leurs plans de vacances et même les
projets de retrouvailles françois
legault vient de dire en point de presse
qu'il va faire des annonces la semaine
prochaine il aimerait que ce soit plus
que 10 personnes dans les fêtes de noël
mais ça va dépendre des hospitalisations
des niveaux de spécialisation clair
c'était dans la conférence de presse
également d'autres tares dubé de
vérifier ce n'est plus tant le nombre de
coquilles et qui perturbent qui les
préoccupent mais surtout le nombre
d'hospitalisations et le nombre de sites
alisation grave en conséquence je pense
qu'on peut penser avoir une période de
fêtes où on voit ce poids se retrouve en
famille mais la prudence demeure et si
on a voyagé si on a réservé des des
voyages ou si on prévoit des
déplacements se répliquent les mesures
sanitaires elle fonctionne laver les
mains et porter le masque
maintenir une distanciation physique ça
fonctionne c'est les meilleurs moyens
qu'on a pour vingt que la transmission
du virus mais questionne par exemple
est-ce qu'il faut quand même si c'est
pas des nouvelles restrictions est ce
qu'on devrait fermer un petit peu plus
les frontières ou est ce qu'on devrait
retarder le retour au bureau par exemple
parce qu'on a commencé ça est-ce qu'on
devrait repenser à ce qu'on est en train
de faire parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on achève cette pandémie
web écouter on a deux vies russie est là
qu vide mais il ya aussi l'inflation et
la reprise économique c'est essentiel si
on veut battre l'inflation alors je
pense que comme on le fait ici la
reprise progressive au bureau le respect
des mesures or comme le dit claire c'est
pas parce qu'on est vacciné qu'on n'a
pas à porter un masque et pratiques et
de distanciation je pense que c'est une
bonne recette qui j'espère va contribuer
à donner plus de vigueur aux chaînes
d'approvisionnement et battre ce
deuxième virus puis gardé le premier lac
au vide dans les câbles je vous emmène
sur vidéo
on va manquer de temps qu'il leur faut
vraiment aller sur l'hydrogène vert si
vous me permettez qui est vraiment sur
toutes les lèvres depuis quelques
semaines et là y'a une stratégie
québécoise qui s'en vient au début de
2022 nous a dit le premier ministre hugo
devenir anglade de son côté propose de
nationaliser
l'hydrogène vert est ce que c'est une
bonne idée
christiane d'abord de miser gros sur
cette énergie lors tout comme pour
l'aluminium ans sa vie qui est un
processus à base d'électrolysé on
aimerait une ressource nationale et oui
il faut miser sur l'hydrogène mais de
façon sûre pour des applications
spécifiques
je ne serai pas d'avis de nationaliser
une technologique va falloir investir
énormément pour réduire ces mêmes coups
d'électro lise et rendent sont
attrayants alors il faut se dépêcher
lentement mais pas manquer le bateau se
dépêcher lendemain je me sois clair
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est dans la recherche qu'il faut
d'abord investir ya énormément questions
sans réponse et j'ai l'impression que
parce qu'on dit hydrogène verts on voit
une panacée pour contribuer à réduire
les gaz à effet de serre et avec les
changements climatiques c'est dans la
recherche qu'il faut investir parce
qu'il reste beaucoup de questions
actuellement c'est très peu de
production énergétique on parle du tiers
de l'énergie investie pour produire
l'énergie qu'on va aller chercher
d'hydrogène et chercher quels seront les
meilleurs usages de cette énergie là les
grands les gros transporteurs
m'apparaissent plus intéressant que tous
les autres types de transport alors faut
vraiment investir dans la recherche et
bien faire les choses ça me rappelle un
certain slogan le mois le plan vert
alors j'ai le mien se peut qu'on veuille
le plein depuis en or le plan nord non
non non le plan de rappel destine aux
gars comme ça nationalisation ou
hydrogène bas je pense qu'on doit
vraiment réfléchir la meilleure action
approuvée dans ce dossier là c'est vrai
que il ya une inflation parliez
d'inflation christiane chez les
politiciens quand on se met à parler
nous et d'énergie on a l'impression
qu'on va révolutionner la suite des
choses et qu'on va devenir de grands
leaders nord-américains paie peut-être
mondiaux de cette filière on a droit
d'avoir de l'ambition c'est parfait mais
est ce qu'on devrait quand même limiter
nos ambitions à notre propre transition
énergétique christiane ben oui vous avez
absolument raison si on a des secteurs
porteurs comme les aciéries normale
notamment toute la chimie verte les
secteurs qui utilisent beaucoup
d'énergie qui utilisent surtout du gaz
ou d'autres d'autres combustibles à
l'heure actuelle qui peuvent en
bénéficier et le transport lourd savait
juste le corridor les camions lourds
québec windsor vers les états unis ces
gagnants si on peut dire un jour que ces
gros camions popopo votre voiture pas la
mienne mais ces gros camions seront à
hydrogène mais ça veut dire une
concertation entre les provinces une
concertation
approprié il ya beaucoup de pain sur la
planche alors mais pas les
nationalisations dites vous ah ben non
bah non parce que là on va nationaliser
quoi qu'est ce que l'on excuse à sa vie
l'allemagne investît 13 milliards 10 à
13 milliards de dollars d'ailleurs is
off des subventions de 15 millions $ par
projet à l'extérieur de l'allemagne mais
pour l'allemagne c'est essentiel parce
qu'ils ont du charbon ils ont donc dû
source de d'énergie alors je pense qu'on
doit en profiter pour améliorer notre
performance à prendre ici puis à être
leader chine ou nationalisation que la
non pour l'instant notre énergie
hydroélectrique et les nationaliser et
c'est cette énergie lock on devrait
déployer et sur laquelle on devrait
travailler on a un énorme potentiel
hydroélectrique toujours on a évidemment
les éoliennes qui performent je pense
qu'il faut vraiment sûr c'est vraiment
notre ancrage énergétique et c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut miser les autres
énergies doivent être autour de nous
accessoires secondaire est utilisée là
où elles sont performantes
le groupe transport comme christiane je
faisais ça m'a paru intéressant tout ça
est passionnant je vous remercie merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
bonsoir merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit